احتجاجاته اليوم تاتي في سياق اضرابات
واضرابات اجتماعيه شهدتها فرنسا خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه ففي الثاني من شهر
ديسمبر الماضي بدا في فرنسا اضراب لمراقبي
القطارات السريعه والرابطه بين المدن ما
تسبب في الغاء نحو 60% من الرحلات
المبرمجه بين المدن نهايه الاسبوع الجاري
وفي الثانيه والعشرين من الشهر ذاته غدا
مضيفه الخطوط الفرنسيه اضرابا لنحو ثلاثه
ايام وتجدد في الرابعه والعشرين بدي
ديسمبر اضراب القطارات السريعه بالتزامني
مع اعياد الميلاد وفي التاسعه والعشرين من
ديسمبر نفذ عدد من الاطباء العامين
بالقطار الخاص اضرابا جديدا عن العمل
تواصل حتى الثاني من يناير حيث اغلقها
عددا من الاطباء عياداتهم اما في الاول من
شهر يناير كانون الثاني نظم قطاع النقل
الحضري في العاصمه باريس وضواحيها اضرابا
بدعوه من الفرع النقبي لاتحاد الشغل
[موسيقى]